Let's go next to our caller from the six one
nine area code.
Who's calling today from six one nine.
Hi David.
This is Steve and San Diego.
Hey Steve, what's up?
Yeah, I'm, I'm watching all of this madness
on fold and you appear to be one of the few
reasonable voices still holding on to relevance
in my mind.
Okay.
And everybody seems the question, everybody
seems to be missing X because it's too terrifying
to confront is this objective reality is dead.
It's as dead as Julius Caesar and it's not
coming back.
It's not resting in peace.
And Donald Trump totally understand this.
He operates as neither Larco tech.
I don't know if you've read much HP web prepped,
but AC well perhaps who writes about scary
other dimensional forces has a character [inaudible].
Who is he?
He shows up when your planet has gone insane.
When you're teetering on the abyss, he shows
up and he is designed to be a carnival Barker
showman who can get you to accept the fact
that objectivity and sanity will never be
seen again.
And Donald Trump perfectly personifies this.
Anybody who ignores it does select their pedal
because there was nothing to support them.
Well, what I think is interesting, I basically
agree with you.
I think what's important to understand is
you don't see large groups of people saying
the facts don't matter.
What you see is they just create and believe
their own facts and insulate themselves from
anything else.
So, and that is arguably even more dangerous
because now the mechanism through which we
figure out what is true and what is not, that's
what becomes irrelevant.
And people don't know it.
People are presented with this information
online and they, even if it strikes them as
maybe wrong, they don't have the tools to
determine for themselves whether something
is true or false.
That's the real crisis here.
Yes.
And as Harry Nielsen once said, a point in
every direction is the same as no point at
all.
That is where we're at.
Well this is more like the a, this is more
like Aldous Huxley's brave new world where
in 1984 they controlled which books people
could read.
Books were burned, you know, Fahrenheit 54
51 they burned books, so on and so forth.
In Aldous Huxley's brave new world, it's more
like, it doesn't even really matter that we
don't need to bother trying to ban any books
because there's just so much stuff out there.
Nobody can tell what's worth reading.
Nobody can tell what's true, let them read
whatever, whatever books they want.
We're just going to flood things with a sea
of irrelevance and nobody will know what the
hell is going on.
Yes, and the last thing I'll say here is that,
I don't know if you've studied much on the
simulation hypothesis, the top man, the big
brains, Iwan, mus, et cetera.
Even Richard Dawkins has capitulated to this.
There's no way to prove that we're not in
a simulation.
It's some kind of game.
And the fact is all the evidence suggests
that we are in a game because objectivity
and the things that we use to think are true
are gone.
Well, I don't know about that.
I don't know.
I don't know about, I don't know about the
evidence suggests we're in a simulation, but
certainly I've read about the theories you're
discussing.
The idea of being, if we're in a simulation
that is good enough that it is all encompassing
and we have no way to test its limits and
to see outside of it, we would never be able
to know for sure that we are in a simulation.
It's sort of like the Truman, the movie the
Truman show with Jim Carey, where he was in
a, in a life that was, it was like a studio.
It was a set.
At some point he saw glitches in it and started
to be able to understand the concept of what's
outside the simulation.
If the simulation is good, we would not be
able to tell.
All right, so the last thing I'll, I'll, I'll
toss back to you then.
I'll let you go.
So glitches, there's no other way to explain
the insanity that's unfolding in institutional
systems in the United States and then the
world more broadly.
But everything happens first in the United
States, as you know.
The fact is, is that Donald Trump's success
can only be explained by the fact that we're
in a game.
No one else wants to admit it.
Well, listen, I think American politics is
certainly become a game, but I don't know
that it proves that we are in a simulation
in the way that people like Elon Musk and
Richard Dawkins are are suggesting.
But I really appreciate the call and really
interesting stuff to think about.